en este vídeo vamos a explorar las
proteínas de la membrana sabían que la
membrana celular puede estar compuesta
de hasta un 75% de proteínas la mayoría
de las membranas celulares tienen
aproximadamente un 50% menos de
proteínas y están allí porque la
membrana celular usa proteínas para casi
todo lo que hace todos estos procesos
que realiza la membrana celular entonces
solo para repasar una membrana celular
está compuesta de pequeñas cosas que se
parecen a esto que se llaman
fosfolípidos que se unen y forman lo que
llamamos una bicapa lipídica aquí he
dibujado previamente una bicapa lipídica
que luce más o menos así está compuesta
por muchos de estos pequeños
fosfolípidos que hemos dibujado
anteriormente podemos ver que hay dos
capas de estos fosfolípidos ahora hay
dos tipos principales de proteínas en la
membrana celular el primero puede verse
así y puede aparecer en cualquier parte
de la membrana celular generalmente hay
bastantes en toda la célula esto es lo
que llamamos una proteína integral noten
que se llama proteína integral porque
podemos pensar que
integrada en toda la membrana otro tipo
de proteína que podríamos encontrar
puede estar en la parte superior de la
membrana ocasionalmente puede estar
parcialmente dentro de la membrana o
también puede descansar sobre las
proteínas integrales a estas proteínas
las llamamos proteínas periféricas y la
razón por la que las llamamos proteínas
periféricas es porque están en la
periferia o en el exterior de la
membrana celular la diferencia entre las
proteínas periféricas y las integrales
es que las proteínas integrales están
realmente atrapadas dentro de la
membrana celular como pueden ver en esta
imagen la proteína integral está
materialmente dentro de la membrana y
por lo tanto será muy difícil de
eliminar las proteínas periféricas se
unen y se eliminan de la membrana
celular o de otras proteínas por lo
general están allí para procesos
celulares diversos por ejemplo una
hormona podría ser una proteína
periférica y podría unirse a la célula
hacer que la célula haga algo y luego
irse las proteínas periféricas también
pueden existir dentro de la célula en la
membrana celular
hay otro tipo de proteína que es
extremadamente raro y puede aparecer
dentro de la membrana celular de esta
manera llamamos a esta una proteína
unida a lípidos porque una proteína
unida a lípidos es tan difícil de
encontrar tan rara bueno las razones por
qué las proteínas están ahí para
interactuar con el ambiente exterior y
las proteínas unidas a lípidos están
atrapadas en el interior de la membrana
celular por lo que no pueden interactuar
con el exterior ni el interior de la
célula así que no cumplen una gran
función en términos de ayudar a la
membrana celular a desempeñar sus
funciones vamos a hablar un poco acerca
de dos tipos de proteínas integrales que
son extremadamente importantes porque
estas dos proteínas se encuentran en
toda la célula y la ayudan a mantener la
homeostasis o el equilibrio el primer
tipo puede verse así de nuevo esta es
una proteína integral para que creen que
podría usarse esta proteína estas no son
dos proteínas en realidad es una
proteína con un agujero que la atraviesa
bueno esta proteína en realidad se usa
para permitir que las cosas pasen
desde la célula llamamos a esto una
proteína de canal y como su nombre lo
indica hay un canal o agujero dentro de
la proteína que permite que pasen las
cosas a través de ella entonces por
ejemplo si hay algún tipo de ion digamos
que es un ión de sodio que está afuera
de la célula y la célula en este punto
realmente necesita estos iones de sodio
para realizar un proceso importante lo
que hacen las proteínas de canal es que
permiten que estos iones extras
celulares entren en la célula
normalmente estos iones de sodio no
podrían pasar a través de la membrana
celular por sí solos estas proteínas de
canal permiten que nuestros cuerpos
absorban diferentes materiales del
ambiente exterior hacia nuestras células
y también pueden hacer lo contrario
digamos que esta célula tiene demasiado
sodio y necesita deshacerse de él las
proteínas de canal permiten que salgan
las proteínas de canal por lo general no
requieren energía así que no se necesita
energía a veces llamamos atp a la
energía y otra cosa que es especial
acerca de las proteínas de canal es que
notarán que van con el gradiente de
concentración
aquí afuera hay mucho y adentro hay muy
poco entonces el sodio pasará desde
donde hay mucho hacia donde hay muy poco
pasará a favor del gradiente de
concentración
el segundo tipo de proteína integral muy
importante se llama proteína
transportadora y como su nombre lo
indica transporta sustancias
hacia dentro de la célula me lo imagino
como un guante de béisbol así entonces
si hay una molécula que está afuera de
la célula y la célula realmente necesita
esta molécula lo que hará la proteína
transportadora es proteger esta
sustancia para que pueda ingresar a la
célula de manera segura también puede
hacer lo opuesto puede tomar algo dentro
de la célula y bombearlo fuera de ella y
este tipo de proteína es realmente
importante porque a diferencia de las
proteínas de canal las proteínas
transportadoras pueden ir en contra del
gradiente de concentración y esto es
realmente importante porque digamos que
nuestra célula tiene muchos iones de
cloruro pero nuestro cuerpo necesita más
para realizar determinado proceso lo que
el cuerpo puede hacer es traer más iones
de cloruro a la célula a pesar de que la
célula ya tiene muchos iones de cloruro
entonces las proteínas transportadoras a
veces pueden usar energía o atp
finalmente hay un tipo de proteína que
puede existir en cualquiera de estos
lugares que hemos dibujado aquí y es lo
que llamamos una glicoproteína una
glicoproteína lucirá como una cadena de
azúcares unidas a una proteína y puede
estar en proteínas integrales proteínas
periféricas proteínas de canal notarán
que las glicoproteínas tienen el prefijo
clico que significa azúcar y básicamente
solo es azúcar más proteínas y el
propósito de las glicoproteínas es que
se usan en la señalización lo que
permite que una célula reconozca a otra
célula en resumen en este dibujo que
hemos hecho de una membrana celular hay
varias proteínas diferentes tenemos dos
clases principales de proteínas tenemos
las proteínas periféricas que están en
el exterior de la célula y son realmente
fáciles de eliminar tenemos las
proteínas integrales que están atrapadas
dentro de la célula y son realmente
difíciles de eliminar
tenemos las proteínas unidas a lípidos
tenemos proteínas de canal que permiten
que las cosas se muevan a través de la
célula por su gradiente de concentración
y no requieren energía
no requieren atp tenemos las proteínas
transportadoras que son como un guante
de béisbol pueden tomar una molécula
particular y dejarla entrar a la célula
o pueden hacerlo a la inversa y éstas a
veces pueden usar atp pero lo que tienen
de especial es que pueden ir en contra
del gradiente de concentración y
finalmente tenemos glicoproteínas que
pueden ser cualquiera de las proteínas
que hemos dibujado es un azúcar más una
proteína y participa en la señalización
para que las células puedan reconocerse
entre sí